hello I'm Gavin and I'm Dan and we're
the slow mo guys I'm gone for two
seconds what's happened to what this
happened
hello I'm Gavin dan we are the slow mo
guys yesterday with rhettandlink I
realized I'm just waving this any bladed
things seem to me okay thanks a bunch
for coming to my back garden yeah guys
it is it is an honor to be here
we once nicked one of your ideas for a
video we did the corn drill oh that we
are on your show we did it in slow-mo
made a master Dan speech yep how was it
you like corn I do like or don't like
ketchup on it and I don't like corn and
ketchup I've never heard that well no
one's ever heard of corner cat was it
just rooms for the visual-motor wouldn't
do the same thing no no but what it did
is sore form this corn paste that like
went all up into the roof of his mouth
and he wasn't like nice look good day
sir you know ever right so what we
thought we would try and do today is
saber a champagne bottle open which is a
thing well this is an actual this is
specifically a champagne saber I didn't
know they I thought they'd just use like
knives in that but yeah it's actually
quite it's actually completely it's not
sharp you know what I bet every things
that Lincoln actually touch it he's not
should touch he's not allowed to be a
sharp things okay like you can see what
it's like a hold a knife yeah look at
that it's almost a knife all right now
I'm starting to get worried again one
that might have been a little out of
focus what is the occasion they do it
must be really swanky right no I think
the occasion is when you don't have a
corkscrew you mean I could take that
home and be like where's the court never
mind
just grab though you don't use a
corkscrew and champagne this is cool no
yeah you don't need anything all you do
is I'm just um it away oh you do it away
you're shaking and farm it entirely
unnecessary so it's when you don't show
it's when you don't have a thumb I think
is if you don't have thumbs or if you're
sort of on a on a ship and there's a
wedding or something yeah well maybe
some source well is part of the process
actually breaking the bottle or is it
you supposed to just supposed to work
lip the
top of the rim where the court goes in
and it pops that nd off the end can you
just hold it actually you you hold this
thank you yeah it's like I can hold it
so these chat bottles have been chilling
in some ice neck down for about 10
minutes because it works much better
when the glass is cold and you see
basically this Ridge here with their
bottles been molded oh you see that yeah
see it's a seed yeah it's like a seam if
you pass me the saber what you want to
do is line it up sort of about here on
the ogive is that a woge I've it's a
word I don't think it's used for balls
but anyway and then you want to slide it
along and keep swinging through and
you're gonna aim to hit that little
Ridge there with the with the saber but
we'll see how good you are maybe we'll
do like a little competition between us
okay who's best of it oh yeah
challenge accepted I'm ready who's that
first Dan I feel like you should go
because you you see see no yeah you like
read some instructions okay all right
I'll get but it's a bit of a grim day so
we got the light on shooting this a
thousand friends a second in 4k I mean
I've seen it clean your hand so that is
sharp now it's just like why it's so
weird your compulsion to want to hurt
yourself no I don't want to hurt myself
I just want to gesture over sharp things
right so yeah I've seen it done before
where it's been completely flat where
the rim is basically just right off
nicely so yeah I'm gonna do that I think
yeah I think we should be like I've done
it so I get at least five out of ten and
then the jagged enos of it you lose
marks bore yeah so so you coming up with
a scoring City I reckon like a six I
want to give that everything's okay yeah
yeah w m-- higher than five six point
seven okay yeah we were rating ourselves
yeah that's a fine you say but it's a
six point six
honey field okay yeah I'm fine with it
first try so you maintain contact with
the bottle the whole time well look at
the face yeah you have to oh that was
lovely
okay came off just one nice clean show
[Laughter]
as my concentration face look something
with something way backwards glass went
back yes way to go and get them over
your labs don't look back towards look I
think oh my gosh did you see that it
went right over your shoulder
I think safety goals and then maybe two
gloves yeah focus on by the focus that
must have been not far fine it's not
total blood
look at my confused face look at your
looking at the end of it like you didn't
know my theory is that the glass coming
back towards you as an anomaly that just
happened on the first one I think I
think we should wear safety goggles yeah
if you have them but I don't think it's
gonna happen again because people would
be constantly yeah I mean even just be
having it all the time
ready yes oh whoa I'm annoyed
definitely more points for the cleanest
the cleanliness of that beer I'll say
the sound deserves more place that was
my main contact with the fence yeah you
know I not - drops yeah that is
embarrassing I'm awaiting your rating
which is actually to be honest right the
only thing I would say is that if you
want perfectly it would be around the
whole thing the whole thing yeah I'd
give you like an eight point three yeah
yeah I might get a part-time job at a
steak restaurant you go is this your one
oh it kept a quart I kept the small part
of it I can't even I think that is
actually it one piece that's why I had
the fence because it stayed the cork
stayed with it you totally went on to
didn't you yeah you did
[Laughter]
there we go oh he likes lunch I can even
even the jet was one yours was like mine
came out my tightest split what they
called in happens comes in two streams
yeah so proud as well yeah
the pride face it's a solid grip not
that much champagne burst out that's yes
you get more points for that yeah yeah
right you don't wait [ __ ] hey yeah
minimal the minimum wastage because when
I get the job at the fancy restaurant
it's gonna be very expensive champagne
yeah I don't think you can wear gloves
and I'm asking that again I'm so far my
theory is holding up now I think that
the glass coming back towards you is
just an anomaly that happened on the
first time well this would be in with
that theory yeah nothing came back so
how are you feeling how am I feeling I
feel very nervous because I was hoping
at this point someone would have really
messed it up but we've had two pretty
good hits I thank you okay red circle
yeah okay three two one that's it Ted
did any champagne come out no you lost
no shampoo Oh what am I gotta fight it
thing that is supreme I don't even think
the edges are shot oh look at that look
at that look at that you came up oh you
want to bring in the camera oh yeah can
you hold this with me I'm just a little
bit guys I can't tell you how relieved I
am did your work I'm not sure if fun
like you've been like reading a
wikipedia no I don't even know how to
read I know I said tan you said you
missed we got on camera I believe that
there is it but just plug a possibility
that it could be better because it's not
completely clear so I guess a nine point
nine okay okay it's not if we if you had
a spirit level Dan your theory was that
the bottles are getting colder and
colder so the glass is getting more
brittle so link that sets you up for the
opportunity to take home the win or the
ten right
well let's watch this back first okay
I look really annoyed I wasn't eyes
definitely closed no should be no
champagne not even a drop how do they
even happen no you didn't lose any none
at all the bit of vapor but I think we
let that unbelievable it's amazing how
like the first overtakes it goes further
than the core yeah that's gonna be very
difficult to beat almost unbeatable
because I haven't been able to hold
anything like this for such a long time
I'll practice right I'm really really
out of practice here I go then I feel
like a swashbuckler I mean if I do this
if I if I went yeah then I get to use
knives on good mythical morning is that
fair
again if you beat a ten if you beat a
nine point nine to get it if I match it
yeah okay if you if you get a ten I'll
let you yeah sharp things on good
mythical more I think it's a deal yeah
I'm not gonna give him the tender I
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
didn't want to push too hard again no
I'm ready you know because of this
camera and there's the framerate I took
like four thousand pictures of that of
nothing of nothing happening I'm going
I'm going ham all right three two what
have you done to this bottle the third
time's a charm for now I'm thinking
about my own children watching they're
disappointed and dad
I mean I could just cut out the failed
attempts alright yeah
yeah shaking your head no I can cut out
the failed attempts first this is my
first attempt yeah
yes that's correct it's my first attempt
yeah are you nervous oh it's your first
try look at the determination in the
face is getting more each time
what do you mean each time I mean the
first its face I feel like we couldn't
plan this okay very good
my first attempt I have completely oh
that is very hear anything there's a
little bit lost of you boss more
champagne the talk is I would say it is
equivalent I think it's better than our
two actually definitely but not as good
as curves so it didn't you got a score
it well okay so that was you what your
third attempt
I don't recall okay I I think I lost
can't forget about the other attempts
for that attempt alone I'd give you nine
point four is there any sort of handicap
because it is linked and not right I
haven't I haven't touched a saber like
device really secondly we need to remove
two whole points that the maximum
ceiling would be eight because it's a
third attempt right but because you
haven't touched knives and so long you
get an extra two point ceiling so you
back to there so that means that yeah
Gavin you had the over Gavin had it over
all the best but I think that if you do
all the math I think team rhettandlink
might have walked out of here with a big
oh yeah say yeah we adding this goes
together we are yeah I think you want to
do it cuz one was definitely the worst
one but it was the first it was the
least
it's true well done guys
thank you Gary thanks for coming here
and wiping the floor with us watch my
attempt back you can yes you know what
actually I deleted it it didn't go so
here we have a little bit of damn pretty
right
that's uh that's mine yeah we look like
you're twins you know we do yeah we
doing that little bit right there the
compromise but you can put it right back
on the the bottle him no one would ever
know it was a I was mostly concentrating
on the face I was making the for my
first attempt I think that was oh that's
the excuse you going for I like it no I
really was focused I was like I want to
look and the dictionary should be next
to damn it okay thank you thank you guys
for capturing that you're concentrating
money the extra determination
there's a lot of champagne very cool - I
love champagne look good and you got all
this coming towards camera so and all
soft love it actually
it looks really nice the old one didn't
have any champagne but it's kind of like
that I think actually at a party you
would want to do that it might have what
I like to have that would get people
cheer it I'd like to call that the
constellation of that you really pushed
hard that you see the angle on your
sword yeah about to hit the cap like if
you pause it right when it's about to
hit the cap he is almost in a ninety
degree yeah and then look where the
sword work for us the sword went
outwards right yeah you it went
completely now you're really putting it
let's cut through your flow well how do
you feel that your celebration face was
it was a good one because we're about to
see it yeah champion yeah vindication
now I've seen a lot of videos online lot
of fail videos where they just straight
up explode and I was honestly hoping
that one of us would do that today so
maybe we can sort of skew the results in
our favor a little bit well I just do it
wrong do it deliberately wrong okay well
seeing as I did the worst should I do
that yeah yeah if I pull this off do I
win
it's up for debate you do something
remarkably awesome that I think will
give you guys the victory all right
frame up tell me are you ready ready
parlor tricks you get the victory
that's unbelievable
like technically that's the way that you
should do it is that what you were
trying to do yes yeah yeah you've just
given me the saber and ran away
I take a real wind up here so I'm trying
to smash the glass you just go for it
yeah I mean it was just you just like
you min and look at that angle I mean
this took an absolute like golf swing at
it as well nice straight cork look at
that kit could you do that again I don't
think let's see we're on the cork that
hit I mean it got it caught right I mean
look solid it didn't just skim it I mean
it was a solid or is it oh yeah like I'm
like I just like a micrometer north or
south and that wouldn't have happened
that's nothing but net nothing that was
swish
serious a fire get out there there's so
much emotion in history you know what
this calls for celebration don't just do
a bad job at trashing it I'll try and
trash you this time I'm ready that went
all kinds of backwards goodness me
that's her ass I mean even still much
cleaner break than I've seen look at
this piece coming towards you get my
uncle yeah that's this piece right here
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is how not to
saber but I do think we have to
recalibrate the score because with the
magic that you pulled with that well how
can how can what lean corkage how can we
have a nine point nine and then may only
get point one better than that with the
cork right I mean I think we get our
justice Oh get 1111 man that was ours
maybe it's just a me my time just to
draw okay
okay you know what yeah and then we'll
all be happy we'll walk away feeling
very medium about the whole yeah okay
yeah let's call it a draw
call it a day all right well guys I
think we've done soon bloody good work
yeah we did
she has around thanks so much for having
it thank you coming and being on our
channel we've done a video with you
haven't we
yeah burgers
and thank you very much for watching
this video see ya you enjoyed it
there's an absolute rollercoaster of
emotions don't try this - home do yet to
say that don't know I'll assume you have
to do but we probably [ __ ] yeah then
don't try at home okay what if I said
try this at home
yeah well I think it's three or four
said don't so hey you know you'll be the
one who gets sued we got lucky we got
lovely tie at the end of that there's no
winners no losers subscribe to us
subscribe to these guys the buttons are
all on the screen that's right you can
do it you can do both pour one out for
the homies it's a waste
mama watch and I'll listen out yeah it's
gonna kill those weeds
[Laughter]